so the next talk by Ewing if we talk
about symbolic determining the identity
guessing Thank You bounty I would like
to thank the organizers Ruben team are
doing a mere and also all of you for
coming so I'm you me and I will talk
about it this joint work with copper
Janusz I used a soft symbolic a tatami
and testing where the so called IIT bra
you will say what start a brace if you
haven't seen it so that's the that's the
plow the talk so I will first introduce
to talk or the problem the so-called
epsilon civilization problem for matrix
table host and we also explain why we
started this problem because this
problem is actually a very natural
continuation of the so called an
uncomfortable drug problem which are
beyond the cattle was talked about
yesterday and then I will give an
outline of how to solve this problem and
also make some concluding remarks so
okay so what is the problem
but before introducing the problem I'll
just mention a few notations most of
them you're probably familiar with
already so throughout the talk the field
F is of calculated not to and largely
now the MFE the linear space of an
biometry sees you are familiar with and
a metric space is just a linear subspace
of MMF so throughout the talk Absalom is
just 1 minus 1 and and biometrics is
absolute symmetric if the transpose of a
equals the absolute face so if R
absolute is why it's a symmetric if it's
- wise skew symmetric so you know
and I use as an epsilon F to denote the
linear space of and by a balloon
symmetric matrices and the GL you know
what here is a C and I use mm to denote
the inner space of M tuples of n by n
matrices okay here comes the problem the
problem is that given a type of matrices
we define it to be absolute limit
writable if there exists a and B which
are you bored by matrices such as that
every CI D say a I D is epsilon
symmetric you just want to make this
type of matrices all of them are
absolutely metric it's not hard to cause
this problem as an instance of symbolic
deterministic Adhan testing because of
the follows so recall that we want to
find two matrices say to you multiple
matrices a and B say AIT is AB some
symmetric but actually if this if the I
T if say AIT is absolute symmetric you
just not left them out like T inverse
transpose and T inverse and whatnot
variety inverse and this also gives you
that the it's also absolute symmetry so
it's actually enough to just multiply on
one side so you therefore is enough to
search for one word for matrix C such
that every e aí is absent absent
symmetric therefore we can define this
metric space l back a which is just all
the matrices
no no matter whether is invertible or
not such that e AI equals epsilon AI
transpose e transpose so this is a
metric space as you can easily see and
then now they are yeah apricot of all i
here sorry about that so now the problem
we reduced just to test whether this l
back a contents of full rank matrix or
not so this is a yawn or that basis i
instance of symbolic determinate in
testing and we also assume F is large
enough so this admits a random if I
efficient
therefore our men without a judge
determine basically be randomized as the
instance of symbolic data determine and
then testing and they so this is our
result do you want about this problem
and this is the the technique inspired
by the so called star technique which
was pioneered by James we were saying
around 2009 while he was his a
computational group theorist so he was
working with Peter and he come up with
this technique to basic to apply that
abroad to algorithms and also the
amorous morphism techniques by akisto
even use Karpinski books bank locks and
even use copy and Saxena so this is this
is about technique but our origin
motivation to study this problem or as
from understanding the so-called
singularity witnesses of metric spaces
which I now introduce this is our
motivation so forth by the celebratory
result of cabinets and impact yeah so we
know that actually we don't need to
protest the idea and impede actually we
actually if you put it in NP there's
already implied that strong as metrical
circuit lower bounds in other words is
amongst who funds more witnesses which
responsible for the singularity of a
singular matrix space and we we actually
we have seen yesterday one type of
singularity witness which is the subject
of non-cognitive our problem so that
which is called shrunk
oddly enough yesterday actually these
things noted were not formally defined
so I just defined here so a subspace of
F to the a the shrunk subspace torille
metric space if the dimension of au is
less than dimension of view where au is
a span of the union of the images of you
under every matrix in this metric space
and the commodity run problem basically
asked whether there came a metric space
whether there exists a strong subspace
or not and I'd mentioned yesterday
actually matrix tuples with strong
subspaces are the points in the knock of
the left right action by the SS s Aaron
cross SL on purpose of matrices and
because and also cat actually a
conjecture that this problem could be
put into P in his g35 and now we know
that it means to determinist the
polynomial time algorithms by karl
cuvees calculus or the be run because
and also a joint work on man with cover
and also kb Subramanya so this is one
type of singularity which is if you if a
metric space at the mr xiang subspace of
course it's a singular but unfortunately
there are singular matrix papers without
wrong subspaces for example with them
simply as the wire just a space of three
by three skew symmetric matrices in
other word put it another way if that
that's basically this suggests that the
analog of hot Mary server and before in
the matrix said space setting does not
hold that is if you consider all
bipartite graphs the hot matters theorem
we know that either it has a proven
matching or it has a so-called [ __ ]
obstruction that is a subset of light
vertices whose neighbor is of smaller
size than they said because of this type
of mesh singular metric spaces which do
not have shrunk subspace we know all
metric spaces they actually they kind
somehow roughly classified into these
three types that is metric spaces like
data for full rank matrix and metric
spaces which have a strong subspace and
metric spaces which has not had neither
of these two structures so as the IT ask
us to distinguish between the orange
shape and the rest the non-cumulative
run problem acts to distinguish from the
pollution the blue one from the rest but
there's two problem now to not coincide
anymore unlike in the
part-time met by parking matching case
so to understand what what happens
within this red region namely those
singular matrix dates places that do not
do not have strong summer spaces is very
interesting well it turns out this is
there are scattered with us in the
literature about some examples and what
happened for for example various more
matrices like the Peter mentioned
yesterday that so we do have a
classification for like three by three
matrices and 4x4 matrices but a lot if
we go larger than say five then is
probably not not easy anymore so I think
one thing we can do is basically to to
collect all the singular metric spaces
the interest in the incidences and then
exactly what is happening there and then
hopefully understand this region is
already written more and so that we can
get to solve this as the ID problem
putting this as the I keep remember so
that's what we do and we here are two
classical examples from the literature
by Eisenberg and Harris I studied in the
1980s about Harris from attribute
geometry lavas from the comet Oryx and
the education from linear algebra so the
first example is subspaces of the space
of odd sized skew symmetric matrices you
know that is singular and you can verify
easily that hits it does not have a
strong subspace and also this the second
type may be less familiar that is the
so-called what are called the skew
symmetric induced the metric space that
is how to construct such metric spaces
you just take two pick in and by L skew
symmetry sees a 1 to a n and then
constructed this such a matrix P I we
are the basic idea the first column of P
is a 1 and VI the second column is a 2
times the I etcetera where I lay I stand
our basis vector and this is a singular
matrix based why that because if you
take any matrix P which is the linear
combination of this via
then basically the columns of this is
basically a a I times the vector alpha 1
times alpha then but because this a is
they ask you symmetric then you know
that this vector alpha 1 to alpha n is
in the kernel left turn of this matrix
that's why it's a singular matrix space
and basically I said button Harris and
that Hinson they prove that under some
very mild conditions either they do not
have strong subspaces either so there
are the two classic examples there are
other examples but probably these two
other most of the most familiar and the
most well studied but of course because
we are talking about metric spaces we
know that's a full rank whether a matrix
and the full rank matrix or not and
whether a matrix base contains a strong
subscript or not they are closed under
the left-right action so this then it's
imply that all these spaces equivalent
to them namely left x some say C and
write x some piece they are also they
also do not have a Farokh matrix and
they to also do not have a strong
subspaces so the question is how to
recognize such metric spaces and our
memories are basically gave algorithm
deterministic have them to decide to
test whether they keep a metric space is
equivalent to either the first time or
the second time so that's why
the difference between the break-ins in
the truth reasons okay so the first
thing is just you have a bunch of so the
first instance you just you take these
excuse metrics that you want to Al and
you take the linear span okay so this is
the first instance the second instance
is that you take the P is then we take
the you take these matrices P I such
that the first column is the first
column of a 1 sorry the P I the at the
first column a the ice column of Pia hey
1 the second column is the ice column of
a 2 so another way to look at this is
that you take this matrix is a 1 to n
you put it at the strain tensor and then
you rotate three turns around to look at
there are other slices of the other
direction so that's why they are
different yes that's right yes
okay kind of questions
so that's why our I'm an algorithm have
something to do with the with a
singularity within its problem and now I
will explain the algorithm for this
problem so recall that our tusky that we
are given part of matrix a type of
matrices and we want to know whether
there exist a foreign matrix in this our
epsilon back a namely those matrices
that satisfy that for every ID transpose
AI equals epsilon AI transpose d so we
just want to find a full rank matrix in
this metric space of course what we will
have a linear basis of this epsilon back
a and given any matrix T we want to
either conclude that ease of maximal
rank of and another D prime of higher
rank if you can do that then we
definitely will well good enough here is
one very simple rug increasing setting
that setting so if we have two matrices
C and T such that they see they put out
put the kernel of T out of the image of
D if this happens there's some
reasonable in your combination of C and
T will give you higher rank than T so
this is easy to say you're just you just
write have linear basis consisting for
example first the some some basic vector
of penalty and then had with the basis
vector of image of T this is very easy
if your nose for example one sequences
then it's just the first part first
segment of one sequence
essentially what we will do that is that
if P is or not of maximal rank know any
linear basis of air epsilon back hey
will content the matrix that can be used
SC this is a very strong condition
actually
but the caviar caviar T that is not in
the Euro action it's not in the action
of matrices acting on F to the N but
acting out some other linear space this
is the tricky part
so in other words the egg rhythmically
this is actually quite simple
so we just use the very simple rank
increasing setting but the but we need
to apply to some other linear space and
the analysis is not not that easy and
that's why we need to go to the so
called adjoint algebra and the start a
bra so firstly we make some small
technical condition that here we assume
that this type of matrices
okay let's first work with epsilon
symmetric matrices and then we assume
that this matrices is non-degenerate
that is the common kernel of these is
trivial and the union of the images over
a span the full space this is the basic
you can reduce to this case easily so
assume this degeneracy condition and
then we define the so-called adjoint
algebra of this type of epsilon
symmetric matrices this consists of all
the matrices T such that there exists a
unique see the the exist of the
uniqueness of this existence it because
of the non deterministic condition such
that for every I say transpose AI equals
AI t so you can verify easily that is a
sub area of the full matrix algebra
there is a very simple MP or more
freedom star of order 2 that is you just
map any T in this after own algebra back
to this see we assume the existence of
this thing so this is the antidote
morphism because of because we have the
absolute symmetry condition
and Eddie bras with and he of morphisms
of order two atoms as velouté
vagabrothers or status where they
started this and held more them and why
simple incidence is just the consider
what should the transpose does to the
full matrix algebra so this is that
and now we define a substrate surface of
the Ajanta tripura adj back hey namely
this linear space of starts in metric
elements in this joint hydropower as the
name suggests that they start metric
just said that the T star equals T and
this is also a very simple linear Condor
this is a linear space you can think if
you then you expand the food definition
you just have this for every I T
transpose AI equals AI T this is this is
the simplest you verify that this is
also a linear space it's not a sub
algebra anymore is a shortened algebra
but for now which is your that is a sub
space we have introduced all these a
truant algebra and the star symmetric
element so we haven't so how to connect
to the original problem we have recall
that will our main interest is actually
this epsilon a work back hey and for our
epsilon back hey actually you just is
defined as this then you replace because
if you if the if the matrices are
absolute symmetric now you're just this
epsilon AI transpose is just a I so now
the for that is for absolute symmetric
matrix tacos our epsilon back he
actually just eCos same story back hey
so this is the connection so this
connects what we want to do what we are
actually interested in with all this new
term new terms we introduced
and here comes the key lemma and the key
idea so let's for now test be interested
in the absolute symmetric matrix double
and then we are given any matrix T in
this dust in the any star symmetric
element and we assume that the joint
area of Mecca is el the key idea is that
as I mentioned before you do not
consider the action of P of the Euro
vector space but shown algebra actually
you consider the action of P John
algebra that is distance from any matrix
here to just DMC because we mentioned
that the dimension of action has brought
back here is also as a vector spaces as
morphic to F to the L and this K then
this gives a actual representation of T
as basically a matrix of size alpha we
also connect the for example the curl of
this T tilde with some some more
algebraic terms for example the kernel
des - des is the set of the space of
right honey liters of T and the image of
D tilde is just the right height you
generated by T and we can also verify
easily that these Frank if and only if T
tilde is flood
now we have the key lemma which said
that if the adjoint had a probably semi
simple maybe this is the first term that
if you do not know about associative
algebra is the first familiar term but
basically they said that it is a nice
situation it's a direct sum of symbols
if we have time then I could probably
introduce a little bit more but for now
we put put the semi simple condition on
there for an a4 not full rank T in and
if not for rank start symmetric be there
exist some say in this there exists is
also start symmetric such as I say pulls
out the space of annihilators of T out
of the image of T out of the right idea
generated by T so this is the lemma
which basically suggests that putting it
in other words the city to DES pulls out
of the kernel of T tilde out of the
image of T tilde and this is actually
where this simple rank increasing lemma
will help you and because you can verify
that this is a this is add in your
condition so if you have that then you
have any linear basis of same start back
here will contain at least one such a
such a see
so this is a idea consider instead of
considering beat action on the most
natural thing you consider the
attraction on the contact
so okay let's then the algorithm easy
you just combine the lemma with the
simple rank rank increasing increasing
setting so that is we suppose we have a
vector a which is in very lucky which is
the top of absolute symmetric matrices
and we let C 1 to C kPa linear basis of
this sin Star Betty and we also fix a
large enough subset of field elements
and the abdomen is just as take any non
for octi we can just try all the P prime
of the form say I plus lambda JD so
there are not too many of them
polynomially many and you just choose
the one that's the dimension of say I
plus lambda J T when it applies to grant
hydrobromic hey the dimension is larger
than the female when you apply P to the
adjoint had to probe back hey
so they but this had this undesirable
semisimple condition how to remove that
firstly if the radical of this Ajanta
algebra john Hedberg can be efficiently
computed then the same strategy works
you just computed and your work modulo
this modulo the radical the module or
article means that you owed me back you
to the semisimple setting so this new
assumption holds for fields of cafeteria
and finance fields basically you
probably you are good enough with
actually I'm cheating I'm cheating
because I'm working with a matrix type
of a which is already absolute symmetric
so you see that what's the point of
doing all this the Ponte that actually
the same way when you do have a another
matrix type of a which is which is
hidden by some mass e then the same
strategy or attribute 'href just works
well then you need to handle this mask
because you don't know this e and how do
you handle with that so suppose this
matrix type of a which is which are not
absolute symmetric but she's hid is it
can be transformed from some epsilon
symmetric matrix sample by some e then
you take an ad from the air epsilon and
you can verify that T equals T prime
times the universe for some tea t prime
which is in this our absolute back P
rugby is consists of all absolutes
metric matrices
so we want to compute this D prime of
the current algebra of ypres the back P
so the red ones are the ones we don't
know actually it's hidden by some e so
how do you do that
firstly you observe that to their janta
algebra of back Hale is actually equal
to a John eligible of black P because we
are protecting to the second component
and you verify easily that there this is
a different idea of back Hey and this is
a jon taffer algebra of a QP you see
that the T actually they they match it
when you project to the second to the
second component this is okay but so we
still do not have D prime how do how do
we handle that then we were notice
notice the following that is T times
their epsilon of the matrix typo
consisting of absolute times a transpose
here back a transpose and that mean that
you take transpose for every component
here and it actually equals T prime
times our absolute back be there are
some something you need to verify but
that's not difficult and then you see
that that's all the blue ones we know so
you apply T times our epsilon absolute a
vector transpose and times their joint
area of a back a you do a little bit
transformation and then you get here
so there's mean that we even with a mask
of this e invertible easy you can also
compute actually the prime times that
aren't algebra of this hidden back P so
then you're then you're plugging in the
rest hat you are basically
okay so I've shown the algorithm where
we have a we assume that happy is large
enough we can also compute the radical
but actually without computing the
radical we can also do that but we
require some non-trivial modification
and even when F is more we have another
algorithm to handle this so basically we
can cover all the fields and now the
open questions of course is what happens
for characteristic to fields and of
course getting back to the what will the
to the singularity waiting this problem
probably one thing we can do is that we
can work with more examples of singular
matrix bases with some subspaces there
are other examples are scattered I would
say so
perhaps pick the one that you like and
try to work with work with it hopefully
after gathering enough examples and the
instances we'll be able to figure out
what is happening in the red region
thank you very much
[Applause]
characteristic is not not - because of
this when we work with algebra we
actually divide with - a lot of you know
all the cases so especially when we
approve this key lemma right now at some
point you had said that somehow I mean
sounded like the skew symmetric matrices
where your big problems symmetric you
can deal with and in characteristic -
you don't have this problem so oh sure
yeah they are the same thing but well up
to attack no but characteristic -
basically the other side different
because we see that he is he involves a
and him odd moment in order to you can
imagine that this a lot of times you
want to divide by 2 2
a little bit also you know deceptive
matrices and you're trying to make all
of those yes yes well you just apply
yeah you just applied to see whether
there are symmetrical you applied
separately if you want to know which
hate that case that's also but that's he
that's the that's also to about this the
evoke some generalized the condition of
the so-called formation condition
basically they're same for the same
algorithm but you need two different
because the situation you mentioned
actually you can also define a search on
algebra it also admits if you also
define shown higher brain it also admits
how to move it and he ultimately the
situation you mentioned but we will fix
some of them to be symmetric some of
them to be absolutely a skew symmetric
then how to define all these so all the
strategy works
[Applause]